well the one is real and what is not as
really is really difficult than i i i
can't i can't answer that i don't i
don't know what's real and what's not
one has to hope that things that are
certified organic are organic but what
is organic mean it's a it's a term
that's defined by the united states
department of agriculture it doesn't
mean anything or doesn't mean much about
how the animals are treated it doesn't
really mean much about what kind or what
breed of the animals there are it
doesn't mean anything in terms of how
the workers who are raising these
animals or farming these crops are
treated doesn't mean anything about
where the food is from so does organic
have some meaning yes I think the term
organic has some meeting but I think
that it's not the most important thing I
won't go so far as to say that it's a
red herring because I think it's there
are some important things about it but I
will say this the most important
division in our style of eating right
now is not organic versus non organic
and it's not local versus non-local its
plants vs. anything else and you know i
don't i don't mean to be repetitive but
the message to me the message is very
very clear the way that people can eat
best is to eat less crap to put it
bluntly and crap is processed food and
junk food and you can have organic
processed food and you can have organic
junk food and that food is maybe it's a
little better than non-organic process
than junk food but it's not good food
and that's the most important lesson we
can learn I think
well like I again I think the clear
answer is that as far as your body is
concerned a grape from Chile is better
than a cheeseburger from around the
corner if you're willing to eat turnips
carrots bread you bake yourself frozen
meat a very limited diet you can eat
locally almost anywhere at least in this
country all year round and that's great
but it's expensive it's inconvenient
than it takes dedication I think it's a
swell idea and I think that ultimately
for food to make sense in this country I
think we're going to see more
regionalism and less food coming out of
California but I don't think we'll ever
be at a place where we see no food
coming out of California unless it falls
into the sea of course and I and I think
that if you if you want to be truly a
local either you're not going to be
drinking if you live in the northeast is
either you're not going to be drinking
any coffee you're not gonna be drinking
any caffeinated tea you're not going to
be using any olive oil there are a lot
of things you're just going to be
missing out on that's fine if you think
that that's the highest priority there
are other priorities i think i I'm a fan
of local food I really like local food
but to go back to the discussion of
trendiness in food everything need not
be taken to an extreme and this is
another thing that's being has been
taken to an extreme
if you know if I'm driving say six hours
and I decide to stop at wendy's or
whatever I guess there's a twinge of
guilt but there's also an excuse because
your way and you know you're busy and
blah blah blah and I don't exercise that
excuse very often so I don't really feel
guilty bad i think what would make me
feel guilty 'used and I don't do it is
going through supermarket and buying a
huge bag of potato chips and coming home
and eating it but I don't do it so
why do they choose because they want
something comfortable they want
something they're familiar with they're
all on bacon and eggs right I mean I
don't that's my guess everybody wants
for fried eggs and butter with unlimited
supply of bacon and really really great
toast I would am I being executed I have
to get the scenarios assuming I'm being
executed and i have the it's not a last
meal like I don't want to think about
cancer last meals I want to think about
execution last meals I would call you
know I'm privileged i can do this i
would call my friend jean-georges
Vongerichten and tell him I want him to
cook for me until I tell him to stop
that would be my last meal but I do like
the four or six eggs cooked in a lot of
butter with bacon and really good toast
I like that too